as a great filmmaker as a human being
what was it like
talking to one of the most powerful men
in the world
for honestly and i'm not naive i've
talked to a lot of powerful people
in the movie business there are powerful
people and many of them are corrupted
i've talked to many people in my life
i've been in the military i've seen i've
had other jobs
i have to say i found him to be a human
being i just found him to be reasonable
calm
i never saw him lose his temper and i
mean you have to understand that most
people in the most people in the western
way of doing business
get emotional i don't see that i saw him
as a
balanced man as a man who had studied
this like you there's a calmness to you
that it comes from studying the world
and
having a rational response to it
his it's interesting his two daughters
one of them is very scientific and the
other one's doing very well in another
profession but they they they're
thinking they're thinking family his
wife too was
uh i can't talk for the new wife because
i don't know about it but he's he kept
his family
with great respect he's raised his
daughter's right
he served yeltsin the way he looks at it
he served yeltsin well and he and he
still and he never trashed well uh
yeltsin certainly a lot of people did
but you know i asked him repeatedly
you know was he an alcoholic and this or
that but he wouldn't even go that far he
just respect
and this man yeltsin who was in it was
uh in many ways um ridiculed but in by
the russians and
he turned over the power because he felt
like he was overwhelmed he turned over
the power to this man because why how
many people had he fired before him
several
several prime ministers this that why
did he turn power over to
uh mr putin because
he respected him for his work ethic
and his balance his maturity
and that's what i can say is i saw in
him
as a a poor person a poor from a poor
family who worked his way up
through the kgb of americans keep saying
he's a kgb agent but
it's it's like saying you know george
bush was a cia agent but you know he
became a pr you grow you grow in your
life and he went from the kgb to
this technocratic position he dealt with
many uh problems incl including the
chechnyan war which was a a very
difficult situation as well as
the russian submarine probably several
things happened early in his that
balance that gave him a lot of
experience and he handled them all
pretty well
do you think he was an honest man i do
now of course the question of money
the charge is that he's the richest man
in the world or ludicrous
certainly doesn't live like it or act
like it if you're rich i i've been
around a lot of rich people in my life
you'd probably have too in america you
run into them so many of them are
arrogant i'm actually uh
good friends now with the richest man in
the world oh of course i saw your
interview with mr uh
musk who i i appreciate at least he
speaks really
i i i'm i'm positive about him owning
twitter because twitter has become
censorship
city yes has all the major tech
i mean the censorship that we are now
seeing in the united states is so
un-american
and shocking to me and he's a resistance
to that
yeah i like i like musk for that just
for that only but i also appreciate him
his
adventures from his nature and his
desire to to to explore the world and to
ask questions yeah there's certain ways
you sound when you speak freely
there's certain ways you sound a man
sounds when he speaks freely yeah he
speaks freely
and it's refreshing yeah no matter
whether you're rich or not it doesn't
matter when you speak freely it's a
beautiful actually you must go
and a major point on going back to
nuclear energy you know he was
he never believed in it at first
apparently uh he was going for batteries
right and he did put a lot of money into
batteries he made them bigger and bigger
batteries but
it just as bill gates said it's just
it's not going to get us there yeah and
uh now i think moscow's on another path
he understands the need for nuclear yeah
he's a supporter of nuclear
we're jumping around putin never asked
for one thing never
it was an interview it was free form i
asked anything you want
no no restrictions no rules
as with castro frankly castro did the
same thing as their chef has so i've had
good luck in interviewing free-ranging
subjects people willing to express
themselves he's much more guarded than
castro
or uh chavez because as you know he he's
he's setting government policy when he
speaks and anything he says is can be
taken out of context
but there is no restrictions on what to
talk about none of that nor any desire
to see anything before we published it
no need to check it with them
it was a
completely
do you think he watched the final
product yes i do but i don't think he
made judgments on it i think he was
pleased
um he doesn't go either way you see he's
very it's he's pleased i mean it went
well he's happy for us and but i don't
think he had great enthusiasm uh
expressed it to me he trusted me and you
can see the way he dealt with me each
time he warmed up to me uh
four times you know the first time i
might have been a little stiff uh you're
asking
you don't know what who you're dealing
with and so forth i understand that
but he's used to it now he's he's done a
lot of press the worst press he's done
frankly has been the american press
and not because of his fault but because
of the way they have treated him if you
look at the interviews they're awful
they put first of all i i noticed one
thing as a filmmaker right away they use
a dub an overdub they put a russian
speaker yeah for everything he says
who's much harsher he speaks russian in
a much harsher manner than actually
putin does yeah who's very if you on my
interview i left him in his original
language with translator and i think
that's important because he expresses
himself very clearly and calmly
when you listen to the american
broadcast it's a belligerent person who
looks like he's about to bang his shoe
on the table uh
and secondly the questions are
highly aggressive from the beginning
there's no
there's no sense of rapport there's no
sense of uh well it's why mr poon did
you poison this person why mr wood did
you kill this person why are you a
murderer that means it's blunt
blunt negative television yeah it's not
just aggressive so i
obviously speak russian
so i get to appreciate both the original
and the translation
and uh it's not just aggressive it's
very shallow
they're not looking to understand
to me aggression is okay if that's the
way you want to approach it
but it should be there should be
underlying
kind of empathy for another human being
in order to be able to understand
and and so
the the some of the worst interviews
i've ever listened to is by american
press of vladimir putin so
nbc uh and all those kinds of
organizations it's very painful to watch
um and you saw the reception to the
putin interviews in america was hostile
without seeing it
so many people
criticized
my series without having seen it even
even i went on a show a television show
with this famous uh colbert
you know he's very famous in america and
i was shocked on the show to find out
that he hadn't seen anything of the four
hours he was just attacking putin and
through me
i was complicit therefore i was a
i was a putin supporter and he the show
the show was a disaster it's it's one of
my worst television shows i actually
i had to
just shut up and get off the air i mean
at some point it was embarrassing
because the audience too was clapping
for kobe on anything he said well as an
interviewer in that situation because
between you and vladimir putin there was
camaraderie there was joking
there was
are you
worried do you put that into the
calculation when you're making a film
with somebody
that could be lying to you that could be
evil
you talk about castro you talk about so
are you worried about
how
charisma of a man across the table from
you
can uh don't take that into account i
absolutely take that into account i know
i mean doing castro is
he's a wonderful speaker he's
charismatic so is chavez i think look at
those interviews
i took it into account but putin doesn't
play that game he doesn't charm you he
doesn't try to overwhelm you with his
uh
bon ami at all
he just said okay ask your question i'll
give you my answer straight here it is
and he analyzes it this is the history
of nato this is a history of our
relationship with the united states how
many times have we tried to talk to them
about such and such and such and such
and each time we get nowhere
in fact it's a very
i would like to get along with the
united states so much he's saying that
he's saying it so clearly in all his
words so to play devil's advocate but
he's not making a big deal about it but
there is a charisma in the calmness yes
there is so like
let's just calm everything down it's
simple facts that you can yes you can
you can call
um
so there's like the hitler thing which
is screaming
being very loud charismatic strong
message and so on and then there's a
putin style i'm not comparing those two
there's the style communication of
calmness
and and that at least to me my
personality that can be very captivating
it's bringing everything down the facts
are simple but then when you say the
facts are simple you can now start lying
and you don't know what's true and
what's wrong
it behooves you to do some research yes
and frankly when coming to research
you're gonna have a problem because if
you
go to the americanized versions of
russian history you're going to run into
a problem
and that includes even wikipedia
they will tell you things that are just
not factually supported so it was a
problem in terms of
if you read all the books in the
american the library about putin there's
nothing positive about it uh they're
awful they're awful and a lot of them uh
i had a good relationship with professor
stephen cohen who's the most
i think one of the most informed men on
russia he did a lot of research all his
life
and uh knew gorbachev very well
and
was very
ana analytical about all these
situations that happened before his
death in
2019 i'm not quite sure when stephen
died but i knew him well
and uh
he was the he gave me the best
information i could get i would go to
stephen and i'd say
i'm confused here tell me the history of
this accusation of poisoning against
this person and so forth and he'd
explain it to me in i think very the
clearest ways that i understood and he
said to me once he said most of these
people who go to russia and write this
stuff about putin are going off internet
the internet has really been a source of
a lot of fractured facts here
uh he said pure analysis you have to go
back to the texts all the documents
and to really fully understand but he
under he
spoke
russian and his wife and him uh
katarina
catarina
van gaal who's the editor
publisher of the nation magazine would
go to russia several times
a year and talk to their friend
gorbachev and gorbachev is an
interesting character i've talked to him
interviewed him not interviewed him but
talked to him at length and i like him
very much
and i saw the divide as you saw in the
putin interviews between gorbachev and
putin early on in the interviews you
sense putin doesn't particularly care
for covert trump because he in his point
of view he screwed up the administration
of russia and is responsible for so much
of the disaster of leaving all those
people outside the soviet union
so
these are problems that continue into
the future but
he
at the they see each other at the or he
sees he knows he's there at the may day
parade i i we filmed
and uh he is he he
his attitude is funny he's very human
he says i you know he's welcome he's god
he's got he's pension he's a pensioner
he's done his duty he's there's no
there's no uh animus towards him
even when gorbachev in the early days
you remember criticized him for his
manners in terms of democracy
but i don't know that that
you know that becomes a quarrel but
frankly by the
by the end of the situation uh it's very
clear that gorbachev has now moved
closer and closer to the says russia is
now really under attack this is
he sees it he sees where the united
states has made a concerted effort to
undermine putin and he does and has he's
repeated this several times about
ukraine i think you've seen what he said
you can quote it
and gorbachev is a we have no respect
for gorbachev even even at this juncture
when can you see gorbachev's ideas
printed in most american newspapers very
rarely very rarely and not and recently
not at all so gorbachev who was our hero
back in in the american hero back in
1980s
80s
has now been condemned to the garbage
can so to speak of history
you